[Music]
ah
I insist a lot on the advantages of
the shelter
that will give you more guarantee and that
the past is difficult
[Music]
ah
will come to the United States but as
the father brought them here and then
from here he was told we could
fix papers or ask the shelter myself
I asked for shelter and they told me that Kim
jong put my sister studied if she
I went for four years
I was very afraid to live there because in
front of our house we had a
cantina and jumped once accept one and
they again assaulted a neighbor who
we had how she did not want to give
money to the stab wounds and then I
I screamed when they stabbed her
[Music]
the integration that we have with these
Boys
we overcome a difficult stage of
conductivity and the attitude is incredible
positive that dreams have
continents
the goals of the speakers
[Music]